e aí
[Aplausos]
eu ouço sua voz grave do meu pai me
acordando são seis da manhã o cheiro do
café mistura segundos cuscuz
recém-preparado é dia de feira popular
dia da feira das feiras esse evento
mística onde convergem número saberes
ofícios e manifestações culturais em
dias como o de hoje a minha gente
levanta sei se faz presente para vender
e para comprar para reafirmar se nesse
exercício admirasse o reflexo que o povo
simples honesto corajoso cantada em
prosa e versos a feira de caruaru onde
se encontra de tudo que há no mundo nas
palavras do imortal poeta ou cronista
onildo almeida é patrimônio cultural do
brasil ainda bem bora rua vai se atrasar
menino abre o sorriso fácil chegar na
feira e perceber intacto painel de
personagens que dão vida a este lugar ou
vírus é um privilégio e eu explico quero
ouvir você ligasse não sou gravador ao
caminhar por esse singular evento
poderemos agir
a chamar escutar são de medi feira olha
o jerimum olha o cajá encontra na
quitéria seu amado por sua vez em alta
voz reverberam olha abacaxi e estende
com gosto de tongo próximo amilson e os
preços em como é que estão aí o que
alguém responde então pela hora da morte
seu sebastião o chapeiro o senhor que
alguns dizem outros juram acreditar é
anterior à própria feira atende
constrangido o almoço segurando que
parece ter sido algum dia uma panela de
pressão olha ao redor e me pergunto se
as demais pessoas ignoram tal espetáculo
caminho atento pelos labirintos da feira
à procura de histórias esperando ser
contadas vejam poeta declamando o seu
cordel uma mulher assando tapioca o
senhor descascando o milho que acabaram
de chegar não ainda não meus pés
incansáveis parece querer me levar o meu
lugar para elétrica a feira de
artesanato aqui desde tempos imemoriais
suas trincheiras aqui
é duro dos artesãos barra o trabalho
duro da gente que faz a crônica do povo
caruaruense viva o alto do moura lá da
família fizeram as regras time ganhar o
mundo caminho mais um pouco e vejo uma
banda de pífanos animando os turistas
mas na frente eu vejo o cabra besta
tocando sanfona nele me reconheço e o
cabra mais besta ainda cantando almoço
para dançar tu dança ele pergunta ela
sente ouvir fiquei surpresa não sabe
princesa dançava a moça com toda
educação responde também me surpreendi
não sabia que cavalo falava
e é caro leitor você deve estar se
perguntando porquê dessa paixão pela
feira veja algo sobre esse lugar que me
energisa se reconecta a memória dos que
me antecederam simples assim ia chegar
da hora me preparo estou quase do
metharia mas ainda falta acolher minha
outra grande paixão encaixa sanfona no
peito e o peso instrumentos faz com que
eu sinta raízes crescerem ao redor dos
meus pés esse é o meu lugar o tempo
parece perder a pressa e observa a feira
o mundo aí câmera lenta
e parece me dar a chance de chegar as
coisas infinitamente singelas presença
neste solo sagrado e é mesmo alegria ea
movimentação meu olhar encontra por
acaso o olhar de um menino sentado no
meio-fio as roupas sujas e com ele no
mesmo buraco parece violentá-la o
renunciarem a proteção que ele deveria o
conceder teria a vida feito dele um
homem a minha cadeirinha contar sua
história ou seria ele o menino o
contador de histórias e crônicas ele
escreveria
e com braço estendido ea mão aberta o
menino o homem desvia seu olhar do meu e
conjuro a súplica aos transeuntes e a
feira começa a perder a cor aí falei
descer
é porque meus olhos enchem de água
porque a voz embarga o que impede os
acordes de sair hein
se diz perto de mim reflexão para não
mais encontrar um menino na calçada da
feira ignoro que tenha sido dele mas não
ignoro isso tem razão quem disse que
tudo que há no mundo a na feira de
caruaru a poesia nas coisas singelas a
simplicidade honestidade coragem
adversas caros e um bocado de brasis a
injustiça ea desigualdade mas haver
esperança sim eu diria ea crônicas
bom obrigado
é mas agora eu queria perguntar a vocês
como vocês enxergam a feira se eu
chegasse aqui agora e pedisse para que
vocês fechar seus olhos imaginassem a
feira será que vocês veriam vou fazer
isso por favor quero pedir fecha os
olhos todo mundo se concentre vizualize
a feira o que é que vocês enxergam quais
rostos quais histórias na crônica que eu
acabei de recitar calçada de feira eu
tento contar vocês como eu filho de
feirantes descobri que meu olhar sobre a
feira não era um olhar tão preciso assim
há muitos de vocês devem chegar à feira
com o canto onde a gente vai para fazer
as compras de fim de semana ou até mesmo
uma fonte de renda para várias famílias
eu também chegava a feira assim mas
quando meu professor de português entrou
na sala e disse que havia escrito a
gente na olimpíada de língua portuguesa
eu descobri a lei que eu ia ter que
olhar a feira de outra forma
e para produzir essa crônica que vocês
escreveram eu tive que descobrir a feira
e para descobrir a feira eu tive que me
descobrir é primeiro lugar agora que eu
comecei eu queria dizer que estou muito
nervoso cu
e em segundo lugar eu queria dizer que
tão apaixonado como eu pela cultura
participar do evento desse com tanta
gente tanta câmera transmissão ao vivo
aos 15 anos me dá esperança que nós
alunos podemos ser de novo o centro das
discussões sobre a educação e que junto
com vocês a gente pode lutar por ela
portanto hoje é o dia muito importante
para caruaru por isso eu queria
aproveitar esse espaço para compartilhar
com vocês ao que vem me preocupando me
permitiu explicar caruaru nós somos a
capital do agreste pernambucano
cidade-polo nós temos o maior e melhor
são joão do mundo somos a capital do
forró temos um maior centro de artes
figurativas das américas que é o alto do
moura é indiscutível que caruaru já
alcançou um patamar o texto em relação à
cultura se a gente for prestar atenção
suja e grandes artistas aqui seja na
música na literatura no teatro mas o
ponto é
ou será que a gente conhece de verdade o
lugar de onde a gente veio ou será que
há algo mais sobre a nossa história a
nossa cultura que a gente dá ainda não
conhece ou se conhece ignoro
e o nordeste eu garanto a vocês que é um
dos lugares mais diversificados do
brasil vocês prestarem atenção
pernambuco pernambucano não fala igual
baiano paraibano não falei para o ao
potiguar nós temos o recife o frevo
temos o maracatu na bahia temos o coco
na paraíba daqui do nordeste saíram
grandes personalidades para o brasil
chico anysio no humorismo dominguinhos e
luiz gonzaga representando nossa música
professor paulo freire
o nordeste é o único é belo mas assim
como a feira ele apresenta uma série de
problemas e desafios e esse é o fato um
desses desafios que eu quero tratar aqui
é justamente esse será que a gente tá
cuidando do legado cultural que estão
nos deixando
e na minha experiência na escola não
convive com meus colegas são muito
poucos os que conhecem luiz gonzaga e
dominguinhos - ainda são os que escutam
e valorizam a nossa cultura eu me lembro
que quando eu troquei de sanfona entrei
na sala de aula toda alegre cantando
luiz gonzaga e aí eles falaram que era
música de velho música feia chata aí o
rebate dizendo que a cultura é cultura
mas é chato
e a gente não tá dando valor merecido a
nossa história esse é só um exemplo a
minha geração tá mais preocupada em
olhar as coisas de fora do que já beleza
do que a nossa o direito e eu me
preocupo mais ainda quando eu relaciono
isso com a educação pensei comigo o
quanto os alunos deixam de aprender
sobre o que nós somos como nós chegamos
até aqui quando não são incentivados
quando nos ensinar sobre a cultura sobre
o nordeste sobre caruaru e por exemplo
se a educação não investir na cultura
como é que nossos filhos e netos vão
entender que nós fomos
e como é que a cultura vai ficar viva
senão incentivamos a nova geração a
tratar dela cuidar dela como é quem
serão nossos próximos sanfoneiros quem
serão nossas próximas artesãos do barco
artesãos
e isso me preocupa
e não pode acontecer a gente tem que
começar a trabalhar de agora quando eu
caminhava pela feira para quando ele
chás para colocar na crônica
e eu percebi que me olhar tava ficando
apurado com cada feira que eu conversava
que era tão parecido comigo eu vi aqui a
mudando cada pedacinho de mim eu senti
uma coisa um negócio de explicável eu
não sei se você já sentiram alegria no
coração da vontade da gente não saí mais
daquele momento do mesmo jeito que eu tô
aqui não dá mais vontade da gente sair
dali e na mesma hora me veio a vontade
de que meus colegas se sentissem aquilo
17 sem o qual a importante preservar
aquilo que estava diante dos meus olhos
cuidar daquilo eu queria que a meus
colegas fosse apresentado o filé da
cultura nordestina não entenderam eu
explico dizer que que achou só gosta de
osso mas você pegar um cachorro
vira-lata colocar um ossinho filé ele
vai comer o filé porque o cachorro não é
burro ele quer o melhor o problema da
nossa sociedade em que sempre coloca o
osso para o cachorro não tem nada o
bichinho comer o pessoal diz que é só
gosta de osso
e a nós estudantes está sendo oferecido
o osso na nossa cultura
e pense comigo quantas vezes você na sua
sala no seu gabinete na sua escola
apresentou o filé da nossa cultura aos
estudantes quantas vezes você chegou na
sua aula de artes e levou sei lá uma
peça de artesanato do alto do muro para
mostrar seus alunos
e quantas músicas de luiz gonzaga você
incentivou os estudantes a escutarem eu
não tô falando em dizer cultura uma vez
no ano no aniversário da cidade chegar a
olha nós temos alto do morro nós somos a
capital do forró não a cultura tem que
ser tão valorizada como português e
matemática até ficar fundamental para
nosso convívio tem que ser retratada
todo dia na escola
ah e por isso é ela precisa ser mais
valorizada educação precisa investir nos
estudantes
e agora queridos professores educadores
e educadoras eu pergunto a vocês a
olimpíada me deu a chance de descobrir
minha terra
e mais quando passarem as olimpíadas
como é que vocês vão fazer para nos
apresentar caruaru o mestre ariano
suassuna costumavam dizer que um país
que renega sua cultura vai morrendo aos
poucos mas eu não quero acreditar nisso
eu quero ter esperança de que meus
colegas vão saber quem é o nildo almeida
eu tenho esperança que um dia meus
colegas de turma vão conhecer vão saber
quem foi vitalino vão saber quem foi
galdino teresa nicinha
é mas hoje eu quero fazer um convite
e vocês topam se juntar a mim para lutar
pela nossa cultura topam juntar forças
para ajudar ela prevalecer então vamos
voltar a minha gente é isso que a gente
precisa fazer o quê quando meu olhar
encontrou o do menino na calçada da
feira eu escolhi aceitar que a feira é
bela mas apesar de bella ela tem suas
desigualdades e injustiças escolher
aceitar também que apesar das igualdades
e desigualdades injustiças da feira esse
espaço merece a nossa luta
e esse espaço merece que a gente cuide e
aí bora lutar muito obrigado beijo tchau
e aí